you
hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast gene expression profiling
during infection
I'm Christina Jewell of lab roots and
I'll be your moderator for today's event
we are delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by lab
roots and sponsored by nano string
technologies nano strength technologies
is a publicly held provider of life
science tools for translational research
and molecular diagnostics the company's
technology enables a wide variety of
basic research translational medicine
and in vitro diagnostics applications
for more information please visit WWE in
comm we have a few important
announcements before we begin this
webcast is designed to be interactive
and we encourage you to ask questions
during the event you can submit
questions by typing them in the Q&A box
which can be found by clicking on the
green Q&A button at the lower left of
the presentation window we'll try to
answer as many questions as we can you
can enlarge the slide window by clicking
on the screen icon in the lower right
hand corner of the slide window if you
have any technical problems viewing or
hearing this presentation please click
on the support button at the top right
of your presentation window or submit
your problem through the green Q&A
button lower left this is an educational
webinar and thus offers free continuing
education credits after the webinar is
over please click on the CD button
located at the bottom left hand corner
of your webpage and follow the process
of obtaining your credit I would now
like to introduce today's speaker
when jishu PhD when g xu has been with
nano streams since early 2016 as a
technical service scientist
prior to joining their team he earned
his PhD and did postdoctoral work at
columbia university studying the yeast
genetics and infectious punji dr. Xu did
Apopka
and drug discovery based research at SBP
medical Discovery Institute he was a
senior research scientist at Carnegie
Mellon University focused on gene
expression profiling infectious diseases
dr. Xu has authored or co-authored 30
publications I will now turn it over to
dr. Wang Zhi Shu for his presentation
dr. Xu yes Thank You Krishna for the
nice introduction so I will ask that my
stamina so today I'm going to introduce
how the nemesis and counter technology
the platform can be are used to study
infectious disease in this case Candida
albicans so Candida albicans is a major
human pathogen it affects more than
400,000 people worldwide per year and
among those patients there is a very
significant death rate so that there's
about 40% of mortality rate among our
people are with invasive infection by
this pathogen even with are hospitalized
therapy the suspect village as
accessibility caused by this patterning
is mostly due to a weakened immune
immune system or the presence of our
implanted medical device such as
artificial joints heart valve and which
you know basically provides a niche or
surface for biofilm information under
the development of new therapeutics for
this pathogen is in the utmost
importance as shown you know in the on
to little graphs below there is the
length of stay in hospital is
significantly longer hour for patients
with our English for candidiasis versus
the control group is less than 10 days
with the candida infection it's almost a
month and the cost also is modern
to enfold bigger for the people with the
camel infection and what we know about
this person Candida albicans is that
it's kind of similar to the Baker see it
can grow in the yeast form or the - fall
and on many surfaces this pattern can
grow in a film called a bathroom
bathroom is a mixture of the hyphy and
some East and this bathroom formation is
closely related to infection and most of
our knowledge about Candida albicans is
derived from in vitro cultures you know
like those you grow our other plate or
English in interpreters it's because
it's very easy you know to get enough
stealth ground and those and English
under those initial conditions and
collect enough cell you can use their
biology can isolate RNA DNA and do all
sorts of tests however what we really
want to know I needed to know is what
does the person do during a real-life
infection it could be mucosal infection
like a flush or a more severe invasive
infection when the pathogen actually
invades internal organs like a kidney
liver and spring and then make columns
inside of those organ which is actually
Baddeley and so to study the real
infection we generate mouse models where
the can up can is injective are given to
a to a mouse and from a food and then
that could cause pulsing mucosal and
invasive infection and as you can see
you know that a red organ that is a
kidney from the mouse and the white spot
I mean that kidney is an edge of Candida
albicans
colonies after the invasive infection
and this is what actually I'm going to
talk about today is the invasive
infection and how as the attaching to
building that infection we can learn
from expression profile and we can also
see how the drug treatment under such
conditions would affect the cells from
also how the the host response is you
know when the infection happens so the
challenge of doing those study in vivo
is due to is actually illustrated in
this figure so as in any infection when
you try to get the infected tissue out
of in a patient of a mouse model and
when your eyes of an RNA what you found
is that the majority of the RNA or the
tissue of the cell you get is from the
host only a tiny portion is from the
pathogen in the case of Candida albicans
initial infection are in the kidney
specifically about 99.9% of our maybe
isolate is from the host only point one
percent is from pathogen and this why
this is a problem it's because in many
of the existing gene expression
profiling platforms such as a microarray
or our mystique um it's very difficult
to handle samples like this it's a mixed
sample with only a tiny portion of the
RNA in what you are interested in and
this could cause a lot of background
noise for our microarray and for RNA
seek um basically you waste a lot of
your reading the host RNA and also this
is pretty demanding for the data
analysis
you know to summarize you know the
challenges are first in vivo versus in
vitro response we know now that gene
expression in vivo often differs
significantly from observations in
neutral so you cannot just study you
know they're on the packaging and test
tube and assuming that you understand
how the person works during an infection
well the second thing is that on really
there's great community to study a time
course treatment and as well as immune
response during a real-life infection we
want to understand both side of swelling
how the House of expenditures packaging
how does the testing survive under the
host immune surveillance and also you
know in a real on life infection series
much feasible to study and hibachi and
resistance versus the efficacy and
another issue from in vitro study is
that there's always a scarcity of tissue
samples you know if what if the type of
infections are known samples is divided
between multiple individual tests and
I'm also really not more and more we
need some kind of multiplex and
methodology that that can generate lots
of data from very little sample another
the third point is as I just talked in
the previous slide that is RNA question
our little host Ani is usually around
one to a few hundred is to 1 to 10 mm so
there is really a very big amount for
for the platform with with a put limit
of detection as well as you know for the
specificity as well and last but not
least is that you know the time to
answer an issue when you know the
traditional testing test identification
could take a days if not weeks but
patients cannot wait that long you know
for the right drug to the other
manipulative
and also there's a need for really
experiences data analysis many of the
regular platforms the data analysis
would require you know a few weeks by an
informatics
institution again you know this is
really a good aunt prevention and
research are diagnosed to from going
ahead at other speeds that we want so
today I will introduce in the name of
thing and comfort technology that
actually would meet all those challenges
so first of all and the anthem is a
really a sensitive on platform it
requires less than a hundred nano grams
of total RNA for RSA with 800 attracts
quantification basically you can study
you know the expression level of 800
genes and in many cases including
proteins in a single assay and also
within us a single as a same tube you
can study multiple pathogens as well as
a host response and the workflow is
really simple there's no end on there is
no library preparation and there is no
amplification media and you can even use
cell lysate directly if you know if you
have multiple samples to ask to handle
with and you can watch to honor a
solution for each one of them and the
all hands-on time up from RNA to the
data is only 15 minutes that 50 minutes
is for all for one country worth of epi
including 12 samples and the overall
sample to answer on time is about 24
hours that's including you know your
ionic prep and your load on the machine
the machine without and so this is
really ideal for any time cost studies
as well
as for passing identification and this
system really got our face covered now
we can use this platform for identifying
you know what country is calling me the
infection and you can do gene expression
profiling for the packaging and with the
same system same RNA you can also add
assess you know immune response from the
host as well as drug treatment responses
so first before I get into the real data
I want to give a very short brief
introduction about the encounter
technology so this is a digital hybrid
value stream based the technology to
count particle molecules as one by one
so it's a purely digital and so the
chemistry is illustrated on this slide
we use to probe we called half-site so
the capture probe with 50 bases that is
that can bind it to the target is a link
that to abouting and the bottom will
help making capture the target and
attach it to the imaging surface and the
seventh half of the probe part of the
pot probe would have six positions and
four color barcodes
linked to the - it's so that our energy
system can take a picture of that
barcode and now rate regime they
sparkled represents so with using those
two half-sites on text and chemistry we
really can capture our pattern now
efficiently and allow specifically
so this slide is showing you one image
from our digital analysis system and for
each method we capture from a few
hundred to a few thousand such images
for each sample so if you enlarge a part
of this image this is exactly what our
system can see at the molecular level
each of those different combination of
black holes is actually attached to
attack the molecule that which you
cannot see so this is really one-to-one
correlation between your target and the
back roads so each of the back order
that we can count here actually filed
our system which is a hundred and
automatic you can actually read out all
the untitled molecules one by one and
and for each essay the capacity is about
two million counts so all the genes that
in that's you know you include in the
code set which is up to 800 different
targets they were sure about two million
counts so you can you know so for gene a
so the next page showing you on the
output of the data from our system so as
you can see here for for the gene called
SP p1 we in Group A there's eight
thousand counts so basically that means
we can detect eight thousand copies of
that gene in the sample while in Group B
need only two hundred and large
transcripts and in Group C there is 948
copies and then you can do a simple
division between those columns and you
know the expression ratio between the
different samples that's that's that's
that you know that's really the the
basic of what you can get from those
samples
um so uh we also provide a free software
called M solver where you can download
the data from the heated analyzer and
put of the data into the end solver so
the ends over can perform all the
background subtraction or the
normalization for you and also build you
the ratio between your samples for you
and the more than that the answer will
also have those some statistical our
package included and that can generate a
lot of unusual problems such as box
plots scatter plot and the heat maps by
clustering both samples and the genes
based on their expression levels and so
essentially once you gather their data
you can use the end server to generate
all the units for our useful figures for
understanding of the data and for
publication as well and so this slide
showing you on the flexibility for the
simple input that encompasses them can
take this is a plot between the purified
and total RNA a hundred and Grandpa's
death and and then on the other accesses
that's there are global ice age so this
in tuning you that the cell isaacs to
recognize it and the purified RNA
actually have very good a coalition in
accounts for all the genes being
analyzed here and also the system you
can also use FFPE samples fun called
needle aspiration and samples it's very
flexible as well you get enough muted
acid RNA DNA in some new applications
even a protein which we you know we
label which ways with some new classes
you can depart with this platform and
it's all in the same length same too
so now I will get into they are the data
from the Candida albicans initial
infection study and before I start I
want to mention that all the data I
described today here is from two papers
that I published in 2015 and early this
year the first paper is in the main
study where we performed all the assets
on the mouse model and the setting of
paper in general of visualize experiment
experiment experiment this is a mess of
the paper so this paper not only
contains a very detailed protocol of how
to perform the isolation as well as
memory and content FA for infection
disease for universal pattern in space
reading and studies it actually and
shoot a video of me doing experiments so
if you are interested between on doing
similar assays if you wanted some
guidance on how to perform those SS and
if you want a very detailed protocol for
a reference
you should put out to the setting of
paper the method paper and both paper
are actually publicly available you
don't need any access code for that and
the work is funded and performed by
initials lab at Carnegie Mellon
University in collaboration with Scott
Phillips lab at UCLA and so now as just
some experimental set up for the study
so what we do is we use a mouse model we
are inoculated with the mouse about Hell
veins which can the applicant and then
that's called pan zero and then after 12
24 and 48 hours post infection we will
separate sacrifice mouse
then take the tissue out that tissue
here is after the kidney because kiddin
is the main packet organ for a cane the
African and infection and then we
actually are made from the infected Iran
to a Cuban tissue and then we perform
nano streams Arjun excellent expression
profile when you the two different code
sets a 250 genes environmental response
gene set and the 230 target transform
factor are coded and after that we also
studied the test for function treatments
using the same infection model and the
last place we are also quantified host
immune response during the same
infection time so the first experiment
we did we call it a knowledge based
approach so as I mentioned before we
have a ton of knowledge about an
expression about the mutations about
what kind of condition is the favorable
or unfavorable for Candida albicans from
in vitro studies right from the study
amplification test use so as we know
that the Nano tree is not a genome-wide
which means we cannot study every single
gene in a chicken in a genome in the
case of tender a became that 6,000 genes
Prather - so so we needed to select
Jeanne's of particular interest for
infection of all databases which is
religion so how do we come up with you
know which gene - sorry so what we did
is we collected all the data set that is
available that is published to date
those data that are mostly from
microarray and some original ones are
from honesty and so those include
studies about zinc iron limitation
and oxid of the deep oxidative stress
osmotic stress and also exposure to
serum or 37 degree which is a kind of a
mimic of the in vivo conditions and also
this includes mutations or signaling
pathways changes and as well as for high
fall and the five film growth which is
directly linked to infection so I want
to stress that all those studies are
mostly in vitro studies where you know I
needed to get but they tell us a lot of
things about the kind of applicant and
from those studies we collected 250
genes that representing diverse
environmental response pathways and we
made probes against those 150 genes and
we use those probes for the in vivo
study which I'm going to prevent so here
is a figure showing you that what
happens to load 450 genes during the
infection at 0 12 24 48 hours so the
baseline is zero time point where you
know the candida is alighted before it
gets injected into the mouse philosophy
and then at 12 24 and 48-hour time
points we collected our samples from 3
to 5 a mouse and then we do the profile
calculated average expression level and
made this figure so what you can see is
that there are genes that is upregulated
which is shown in a bright yellow color
here in at all time points starting from
12 and that is Ginny lap and all the way
to 48 hours we didn't carry them expand
to much longer than 48 hours that is
because on the mouse is starting to get
really sick and some died after that
time points so the cutoff is at 48 hours
and there is genes that is actually down
regulated which is shown in blue from
the beginning to the end
during this infection time course and
the more interesting a their genes there
is a dynamic change during that
infection time nine so for example we
can see there are some genes that in
blue which is now regulated as a
beginning and that can be yellow which
is up ragged towards the late part of
the infection you know I want to stress
that that edge mix make a lot of sense
because turn out those genes that is
turned on later is actually on some of
the updates oxidative stress genes or
our acquisition genes so we know that
neutrophil actually infiltrate into the
sides where the infection happens and
that adipose and oxidative stress to the
passion and the passion you truly
respond to such a stress so that all
fits pretty well so so now we have a
very nice big set for the in vivo
infection and how does that compare to
previous tips that you know from
numerous of the lab where they perform
the knife expense in vitro so it turns
out that the theme is in vivo which is
on here labeled as kidney 12 24 48 hours
kind of reproduce some of the signature
some of the gene expression profile that
is shown under a number of conditions
such as you know exposed to theorem 37
degrees the osmotic our oxidative stress
but none of the envy for one of fully
represents the profile that we observed
from this in vivo status so this tells
us in vivo you know is really complex
and a unique environment that the
artistry needed to
respond to in order to survive and in
order to you know invade in order to
colonize so so that's about the amount
of response gene coded them well
similarly we decide to decide to take
more on discovery based approach so here
if we have a more open-ended oppression
so we don't assume we know anything
about on you know what the peach in do
so we think we as a question how about
if we study all the cell wall components
of the secret protein are for patching
ask which officers those proteins are
genes are actually necessary for the
infection or how about we studied all
the protein kinases or how about we
study other transcripts trans women
factors and here I'm going to present
the data for the transcription factors
and there is a 230 known of predicted
genes in the can of genome that
specifies a transferring chapter we made
a probe for each one of those and the
way applied this probe set to the same
any prep that we justice was so this
turned out that we have some
observations that is similar or to what
we have with our first codes that are
environmentally Stamkos that here again
we have genes actually factor that is
upregulated early on or downregulated
earlier and as well as transferring
factors as is dynamic that is our and
off depending on the time point you are
taking action during infection so one of
the transition factor that is to now
early is that one and that is required
for zinc acquisition and this fits very
well with what we learned from the
mantle response gene called that where
all the zinc acquisition genes is
pronounced and as well as all the genes
for iron acquisition
that is also $10 a.m. and an interesting
one that is sound regulated called and
rg1 this is a repressor of Haifa growth
and we know that immediately after the
on the kind of cells enter the the host
it will start to form
- which indicates them the president of
the Haifa growth should be tender so
everything fits pretty well so the next
question is that okay now we have a
dataset where a lot of genes in this
case transferring factors studied and we
know some of them are regulated some of
the Munchkin can kill the mice along
with a five or seven and those
transferring factor mutants actually
failed to do so so as you know that we
put out a lot more on sensing factors
with the same expression pattern so
obviously we can study those transition
factor to see whether they are indeed
also play a critical role for infection
so again you know this data set serves
as a nice hypothesis generator and
lastly we also use the same RNA and
looked at the host immune response
during infection and in parallel to what
we observed from the patient side of the
story
we noticed there's a host immune genes
that is turn out early such as TNF alpha
our six Minko and adapting to and as
well there is other immune response
genes that it can earn at a much later
time point at 48 hours so this includes
our 17 not gtr2
in the figure beaming here what I'm
showing you is that we compare the
overall immune response from the for our
representative genes
when the mouse is infected neither by a
mutant strength where the sum of the
Cheney transient factors has been
knocked out or from our company industry
where the gene has been put back to the
mutant strength so in all six cases
there is a significant difference in the
amount of immune response that is
induced by the complementary strain
versus a mutant strain and this is not a
surprising because we know that a mutant
strain fail to really cure the mice so
so the colonization levels the number of
RCF use from program of tissue is much
lower from mutant and this is also
reflected from the more muted response
from the host immune system and we also
compare our you know study which is
excellently infection in recent
infections to new culture infection
where basically it's a flush flush that
Candida impacts on the tongue and what
we observed that there are some genes
that is turned on in both types of
infections often the disease genes that
can are only in the kidney infection and
there is gene turn are only in the town
infection so this helped us not only
that initial and in vivo expression
profile is very different in fact
different infection size different
infection types also would induce very
different gene expression profiles in a
lastly an interesting thing we did is
look at the response to attackable
function which is a main drug used to
treat can an African infection in
hospital so what we learned is that
there's actually 6h jeans that is turned
on induced by the Californian treatment
in leisure vigor we mean sales from in a
test tube a flask with in our PMI at 37
degrees with serum present and there's
about sixty four genes that is induced
in vivo however there is only a small
lab overlap of those and genes that is
commonly induced in both conditions
there is actually 18 of those that is
induced by cattle function in both in
visual and Henryville so this tells us
one thing is that as a response to the
drug treatment or in to actually in a
map or tend to any therapy in quite a
different in vivo in a real infection
versus individual in you know in our
test tube so this illustrates the
importance of studying the drug response
or developing new drugs under the in
vivo conditions where you know you work
in a module response so that's that's
the data I'm going to translate so
finally I want to give a you know a
civilization of the system why narrow
stream system would be a feasible
platform to perform this kind of study
the first of all nano stream is very
flexible in the kind of input you can
give it its you can FFPE samples or like
it and to sell message and also you can
give it fixed an examples where just a
passion of interest may occupies may be
a very tiny portion of it now secondly
is that the workflow is really simple
and fast on as I sell time downtime is
only 50 minutes and the overall time is
avoiding 24 hours Nick Nick
feasible for multiplexed multiple sample
time course studies and also the video
is reducible and precise which one
barcode is a single target so it's
really one to one digital camping and
you can add up to 800 genes at a time
and the data analysis is really
straightforward and solver Beijing
excels at all so in summary you know the
high sensitivity the specificity and the
reproducibility of this and Kanto system
will really make it a suitable platform
for infectious disease research
another implanting is the system has a
greater dynamic range we can accurately
quantify our genes from less than 100
copies to upper to our million copies so
that there's a attention to this range
of dynamic so you can unzip those high
expresses and low expresses in the same
acid and again you know the simple
workflow and the sphere forward data
analysis really help them to move
forward as your research you know much
much faster pace as compared to other
arm platforms so with that I can take
questions
okay thank you for that informative
presentation before we get started on
the question-and-answer session I would
like to remind our audience how to
submit questions you can submit
questions by typing them in the Q&A box
which can be found by clicking on the
green Q&A button at the lower left of
the presentation window we'll try to
answer as many questions as we can okay
dr. Xu our first question is can we use
this technology for protein proteomics
yes actually we actually it's our new
application called a 3d biology so what
we do is we were able to use antibodies
to label on the protein of interest with
with a nuclear and you can't add acid on
attack and then we can use the exact
same chemistry to detect proteins of
interest right now we have two kind of
offering one is we have a premade panel
with 30 proteins that is related that
you mostly in your knowledge and then
you can that's off the shelf you can buy
energy text that also we're offering our
customer on antibody labeling service
where you can pick up a to 30 of your on
protein of interest and we will and also
tell as you know which antibody that
works great in your hand for those are
proteins in western bras other
applications and then we can actually
label those antibodies for you and you
can then use those for doing something
like the proteomics and although it's
not wouldn't be you know in hundreds or
thousands of proteins at the time but
you can easily insert the proteins and
that you can do the proteins actually
together always the mRNA micron
our DNA so that's why we cost read about
it so yes the answer is yes you can do
that okay next question in your opinion
has nano strengthen more beneficial for
discovery or validation in your research
or both and why I would say both so
actually you know I see you know Nano
should not being actually genome-wide
but it does have an advantage of as I
said simple book warfare and pretty high
both attacks so essentially I you know
as one part of my presentation today you
can actually put it up to 800 genes of
interest so that's what the easily cover
all you know the cell wall protein of
all the human factors are all the
kindnesses from any attacking genome and
put that into encode asset and that
would be a great discovery tool or
hypothesis generating tool on the other
side if you already down you know
microarray are on honesty where you and
then go down of the gene of interest to
a few hundred then the other thing would
have become the platform of choice if
you want to carry along you know
validation or the drug development and
type of assay where you needed to test a
large number of samples under numerous
conditions then nanos view is a way more
efficient and accurate and then the
computing platform so I would say it's
really there depends on your needs and
we can do both a discovery or validation
type of study where this platform next
question have you ever used other
tissues such as spleen liver or lymph
nodes oh yeah essentially this platform
is on tissue I was independent as long
as you can find a protocol that would be
unable you to isolate RNA nucleotide in
that sense from the tissue
new Jean with nano stream and also in
many cases you don't really need it to
even isolate the irony all you need to
do is to do an ice age so like a party
or other kind of unlicensed buffer just
to you know make sure the cell break
open the nucleus is released then you
can just apply a few microliters of
message combined with our quota set and
because there's no enzyme it's directed
hybridizing you play as a deprived
reading based so it's really flexible
and robust acid now can the proteomics
application be used to differentiate
isoforms well that depends on the
antibody if you have an antibody that
you can differentiate differentiated an
isoform and then are attacking you can
so the presume with a petition is
depending on the availability of a good
antibody
now what is a big what is mostly the
biggest difference between micro array
and nano stream I would say it's a
digital versus more analog so you
microarray you look at the fluorescence
and intensity in you know between two
channels here each of our barcode action
binds one to one to a target so the
readout from nano stream is immortalized
each one comes after that our barcodes
represents one copy of the transcript
so our did is a lot more actually
accurate and reproducible compared you
know to to microarray and also the
background level is is way lower we know
that you know our general background is
like 10 counts after 2 20 counts that's
it and our you know a medium express a
gene and with a hundred milligram of
total RNA the readout would be hundreds
of thousands so compared to that is that
one is almost nothing so so we can
essentially detect a much smaller amount
of RNA and in high complex on sample
dr.xu this is a three part question I'll
read the entire question when we can
answer each one as it comes if you like
can this be used to substitute the
actual CSU count to determine the
bacterial burden in an infected organ
and is there any validation or direct
comparison data also will this be an
accepted method by a journal for
publication okay so first I will answer
you know the last question first
yes this is a complete accepted method
for publication
up to now there's thirteen hundred
papers are in our journals like in green
cell science nature that used nano
stream as its core platform for
expression for
detect even for cockiness a copy number
variation which is very any based assay
the certain question is that I can can
this accounts being used as substitution
of in the CFU yes I would say yes I
personally did a comparison of CFU data
with with the raw comes you know of the
housekeeping genes actually they have a
very good correlation I think that is
mentioned in one of my publication and
as well as a number of other recent
publications and also not only that
actually I think I saw that too at least
two recent publications where people
develop those on nano screen based assay
as a way to detect first of which
pathogen is involved in that infection
from a patient sample as well as you
know how severe you know in other words
the number CF you are in the sample okay
next question how much is this
technology quantitative I would say how
much I was it's a hundred percent
digital so
or so this is more more or less we we
you know we promoted it as a mission
metric based on technology so
essentially that our the community use
is less thing if you would have multiple
experiment groups like your control
group your treatment group or your
patient group reverses in the health
control group so the most accurate data
you will generate from this platform is
when you're talking about an expression
difference between to expand the group's
so that's that's our promoting the usage
of this system but I do know that some
people try to use also this platform and
absolutely on quantitative method for
for that purpose yes you can do it but
you need something like a standard curve
so what do you do is you can apply
unknown quantification of the input for
example things that you can easily
synthesized in a known quantitation of
oligonucleotide use that to make a
standard curve for the detection and
then based on that standard curve you
can you know quantify how much of the
transcription that you are interested in
from a certain sample so so essentially
yes we we do from we mostly promoter
than the visual metric usage of this
platform but if you would like to do
absolute quantification you can't do it
with some with carefully mapped out
controls next question how much is this
technology costly compared to microarray
I do not you know it's it's kind of an
apple to orange because the data you get
is not exactly a director comparable
microarray is genome-wide as we know so
you can you know it's a praxis is in the
thousands while nano screen is more in
the hundreds and kind of tracks so you
if you're talking about
caught four per data points I would say
a mockery is slightly less expensive
however the accuracy is after data you
know basically full usable data point I
would have seen a nose ruled away in
that area and also sooner mostly because
it's highly produced ability actually we
have a program and this is a really
accepted by the scientific community and
the publication is that technical
replicates is not necessary for nano
stream all you need to do is biological
replicates so wow you know you had a
platform microarray rnaseq really you
not only need a biological replicates
you also need a technical replicates so
so if you consider take those kind of
factor into consideration also plus on
the data analysis downstream data
analysis is extremely easy basically we
provide the free software so if you take
all those you know man hours into
consideration I would say nano string is
a really cost effective platform in
reference to your previous CSU counts
question can you elaborate on the use
for CSU counts for publication not to
the technology itself yeah sure so you
know the CSU is you know kind of the
coding standard yet in the most most
most like labs and hospitals to use that
there's nothing wrong with that the the
issue is that sometimes you know
depending on what person you are
studying
sometimes it's hard to culture those
aren't pathogens you know in a
laboratory and environment so the CFU by
itself is not also a you know for
example in in some filamentous fungi the
cells are not really easily separable
from each other
you know they give net result - and they
mimic a big grumps so the CFU is by
itself is not a necessary accurate so if
you know if you compare three things CF
you and hits the temperature
where you catch some tissue and stay
them and count in latina bar cells there
which is again another golden standard
and also the nano stream our
quantitation actually turn out that is
an inner stream quantitation correlates
with each other with the HIPAA chemistry
in especially in the case of filamentous
found right where CFU number is harder
to get because of the way that the cell
you know grew and enacting a biofilm
it's it's sometimes you know Wednesday
if you're not a natural mean you know
one when cell are exact time case it's
the radical relation even our machine
dentistry and in the histochem tree but
in general you know the Mafia view you
have a plug from a sample the more are
nano SIM cards with a gap I don't know
if that exactly it got your question but
that's that's my commands what are they
it point for just a few more questions
next one how long did it take to analyze
your samples with the encounter si from
sample input to data input for your time
course study yeah so you know I
performed it this time cause study when
I was in Tunisia Mellon University in
dr. Mitchell's lab so and in
collaboration with a Scott Phillips now
at the UCLA so what we do is start
spillin lab performing all their our
mouse experiments and they will just
send us you know the infected tissue are
a snap frozen tissue to us
so then after collected are in all the
time cause samples put them at minus
eighty and when I'm ready to go
it took me few weeks to process you know
a few hundred so tissue samples
basically I isolate RNA you do 24 on
samples in the morning and then I can
perform basically two cartridges worth
of nano screening assay in the afternoon
so I taking the basically 15 working
days to go through you know about more
than 200 samples and then the data nurse
would take another one week or two I
just you know put it plug into the
answer
and you know conscience on number and
cumbersome figures so they're really
from the sample to Dave and Aziz Nesin
them our final question are you able to
identify multiple pathogens and host
responses within one multiplex using the
Nano string si yes yes it is definitely
possible and feasible to do especially
you know for identifying multiple
patients that's actually a pretty
popular application right now I've seen
two recent papers where people developed
on diagnose their assets under
management platform essentially what you
do is you are design species specific
probes you know usually you know five
six of probes for each species you know
just for you know for the solid you know
for the connector facing is confirmed
you know your own data and then you can
basic applications and poke at RNA on
life aid and apply that and you can
easily detect multiple pattering
speeches you know that would be virus
bacteria are fungi and the second
question is that can we
you know detect person and also host a
response from the same sample as using
the same shoe yes yes but that would on
have one condition that is the ratio
between the pathogen and the host should
be within an tenfold
so dependence or depend on the tissue
type or the infection type in some cases
you know there's a ratio of patching
cell to host is ranging a tenfold
difference in that case yes it's very
easy to do that but in some cases
wearing a new pathogen cell to a host
cell like in the case I presented today
is a one to one down the level
difference in that case because of a
dynamic and range it's highly commander
that are while you can use the same RNA
for the detection we separated actually
introduced the reason is that because
the host ionic dominates the RNA you
know you isolate before you can
effectively detect the packaging all the
reads I would be contributing and the VP
contributed from the host side so in
that case you know what it on you can do
the essay from I think you're on a
solution but you would have separate
your as introduced so that's that's it
but yeah the short answer is you can
detect the multiple pathogens as well as
host responses in a single asset after
she would thank you so much for this
informative presentation I would also
like to thank our sponsor nano stream
for making today's educational webcast
possible today's webcast will be
available for on-demand viewing through
December 8 2016 you will receive an
email from laboratory you when this
webcast will be available for replay we
invite you to forward that announcement
to your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event see you next time
goodbye thank you